all right so the hype is real on this
one before we get started i do want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by nordvpn
nordvpn's a vpn service that protects
you your account and your data from the
ever prying eyes and the spies of the
internet in this modern day world where
personal information is a valuable
commodity and even a currency it is ever
more important to protect you and your
personal information thus i bring this
to you and since we're all movie buffs
and tv show fans here nordvpn allows you
to watch your favorite content even if
you're abroad changing your virtual
location with one click you can choose
between over 50 100 servers in 60
countries so option yeah could it use
that service to entertain myself said
the entire mcallister family so click
the link below go to
nordvpn.com enter coupon code john's to
get yourself a two-year plan at 73 off
and even get yourself an extra month for
free because tis the season and thank
you once again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it and now no
messing around here we go
and do not go into the comment section
what are you doing you know people have
already seen the movie they're
commenting spoilers right now having
their friends accounts or their phantom
accounts give those comments thumbs up
so it bumps it to the top of the comment
section it's an age old youtube internet
troll tactic don't fall for it don't go
to the comment section not saying you
have to look at my face while listening
to me you can listen to my face you have
to look at it do other things do
projects retro games which is me saying
this is not a spoiler review this is
spoiler free enjoy the word vomit coming
out of my mouth my friends you need not
worry here i am going to address some
things that have been shown in the
trailer because you can't dance around
the villains that are in this movie
there was actually someone at the screen
he was like i haven't seen any of the
trailers i was like
good for you what kind of envy so if you
haven't seen the trailers that's great
but i am going to talk about what the
trailer showed in terms of what it means
to the plot so there's that anyhow so
spiderman no way home is the newest
spider-man movie and as the trailer
showed us
it's it's bringing a lot to the table
villains from other spider-man movies
from other spider-man universes have
been brought into this universe and now
tom holland spider-man needs to deal
with that first of all talking about the
action i thought the action was great
especially in my recent re-watch of
spider-man 2. i love the fact that the
doc awk arms are just going after
spider-man spider-man's countering then
counter-attacking and the arms are
counter-counter-attacking i was hoping
spider-man no way home captured the
spirit of that it absolutely did but
it's not just doc ox like you were
watching two top-tier street fighter 3
third strike fighters go head-to-head at
each other safe to say i really dug the
action in this movie also the villains i
like what the villains brought to this
movie granted they are here for fan
service but it was fan service with a
purpose or at least more of a purpose
than i expected to be in this movie i
thought this movie is going to be like
hey remember how cool those ramy
spider-mans were
we remember too jamie foxx's electro got
a great mulligan if we're gonna quantify
the contrast between great casting for a
spider-man villain and wasted actor that
cast as that spider-man villain because
he didn't really do what he could have
done jamie foxx says electro pretty up
there so i was glad he actually had more
to do in this movie you know it's they
weren't just here for the third act
brawl or it's all right sweet see in the
third act because that'll be fun it'll
also make for some sweet trailer shots
you know it didn't feel that way i
thought they did a surprisingly good job
at having this moral dilemma and having
spider-man and the villains deal with
this moral dilemma in a world where the
movie's not six hours long or anything
you can't give every villain their shine
but i thought they did a good job at
prioritizing what
i was going to say the favorites they're
my favorites anyway they gave the ones i
like to see have more to do more to do
which means yeah couple of the villains
namely i mean sandman and lizard what
can i say they're the ones who are the
benchwarmers sandman and the lizard do
feel like yeah you're here for the third
act so go ahead and warm the benches and
we'll call on you when we need you
go
it's not gonna warm itself
thank you thank you well one of the
things that really surprised me about
this movie i felt spider-man no way home
did the best job
among the mcu spider-man movies anyway
it did the best job at not concentrating
on this being a spider-man in the world
of the mcu i mean they still have mcu
references they still acknowledge that
this does take place in that world and
at first it fell as okay it's another
spider-man in the mcu i expected that
you know he's dealing with doctor
strange it felt like another
i mean it's a cinematic universe it's
gonna feel like that until this stops
feeling like that at a point this movie
focuses up it's spider-man dealing with
spider-man villains which is how i
personally like spider-man to feel it's
like spider-man in his own little
sandbox of spider-man it's not like
they're like mcu what's that hmm but
compared to the other two mcu spider-man
movies i thought this did the best job
at concentrating on peter parker and
spider-man first and foremost granted
doesn't hurt that he is taking on
spider-man villains that we have seen
before probably a bit of psychological
play they're doing here and also tom
holland a spider-man at first i was like
tom hall and spider-man yeah and then as
time went on i was like this dude seems
younger than other spider-mans i get
spider-man is young but he comes back
from being snapped to
carbon and he comes back he's like mr
stark there was a wizard and this i was
like what are you five he didn't feel
like he was growing up really i mean he
had some [ __ ] happen to him in the last
spider-man movie
far from home almost called it no way
home and also almost called no way home
far from home but this movie had a
surprising amount of emotional depth for
peter parker to deal with i felt tom
holland did a great job in here also
makes him feel like yeah he's he's done
his rite of passage to feel like a
spider-man that feels more familiar i
mean i'm not saying it's the perfect
peter parker spider-man from the ps4
game personified on screen but i did
feel like this was the most mature
version of spider-man and peter parker
tom holland has played yet my biggest
gripe i have in this movie is my
standard i'm becoming a grumpy ass old
man ba humbug i'm the grinch on top of
the hill gripe that i have about a lot
of mcu things and that's the balancing
of tone there are some moments where
it's like oh yeah that seems heavy that
should probably stay for a little bit
don't go right to the j you went to the
jokes it's not just jokes sometimes the
joke juggling actually does work other
times i was like you just compromised
the tone you did that you did the thing
example this movie starts out with some
epically dark tone i was like oh
okay here we are you got us caught up to
speed with some voice over and now it's
going down bring on the business and
then jokes and swinging lighthearted
things and more jokes it's like oh okay
fair enough but
i mean it works for them they make a lot
of money there is a thing that happens
in spider-man no way home that i've seen
other movies and tv shows do we've all
seen it but there's a character and then
out of the blue they just pull an
ability out of their ass and now they
can do a thing they've never been able
to do before and they can do it like
that yeah that happens in here and it's
really glaring and i don't buy it but
for me for the most part spiderman no
way home i had a lot of fun it is a
fanservice smorgasbord of spider-man
versus spider-man villains that we've
seen in other spider-man movies but i
was surprised at what it did for the
depth of peter parker's character in
this movie and actually what it did for
some of the villain characters in this
movie that i just expected to come in
for the last act to just have a big
brawl have a big fight it had a bit more
than that i appreciate that a little
bias when it comes to spider-man though
i admit that absolutely i own all of the
spider-man movies on 4k the great the
good the bad the middle of the road i
own them all i'm an optimist i try to
find the best that a spider-man movie
has to offer this is a really fun one
and i'll end up buying it on blu-ray or
4k versus spider-man no way home
i hope you like it i was going to say
have you seen it what did you think
about it comment below let me know but
i'm not going to because sending you to
the comments section is just dooming you
to see spoilers don't do that don't even
go down to the comment section to
blindly type in but
just for the sake of the algorithm don't
do that i don't care about the algorithm
i care about you optimally enjoying your
entertainment however as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you